jojo was geht hier ist euer marx und
herzlich willkommen zum zweiten video
heute ich wollte unbedingt noch ein
video machen da bin ich was richtig
richtig lustiges gesehen und zwar von
skype einen bot was der macht ist
eigentlich ganz einfach das gesicht von
irgendjemandem in den körper von jemand
anders ran zu shoppen und ich finde es
ziemlich lustig dass er will ich sagen
probieren wir das ganze doch mal direkt
aus okay das geht folgendermaßen man
tippt ihr einfach rein jg und jetzt
schreiben irgendwie mal angela merkel
warf obama ok jetzt warte man kurzem das
geht richtig flott
was ist das das ist das für ein wesen
alter ohio mein gott wird durch dieses
wesen einfach an
also ihr merkt schon das wird lustig
werden und der probieren jetzt einfach
mal ein bisschen durch ich glaube er
bezieht seine bilder von bing also sowas
wie google und kann deshalb auch
youtuber bzw
vielleicht sogar mich benutzen um leute
zu finden wird
angela merkel wars kram crafter so
dauert wieder kurz und leite angula was
dafür getan um mein gott so dass sie
schon mal extrem nice aus
wir probieren ein bisschen was
verrücktes was wäre verrückter als ich
und angela merkel zusammen
oh gott wenn das funktioniert ok bot
efkon kräfte wars ein alpaka so von
denen ist jetzt luca oder wo ist jetzt
luca das gericht hier was behindert ist
dass es jetzt also überlege ich habe es
nicht gesehen habt ihr es gesehen
das können wir sagen aber wirklich ich
gucke wo ist der größte rückgang ist ein
paar tief im gesicht der im alter das
ist der weg
okay das war schon mal extrem heiß was
wäre wenn krankhaft ein bauarbeiter wäre
dieses gesicht gefasst hat diese super 3
ich glaube du brauchst eine komplett
frontale ansicht von linke sehe ich da
durchaus vernünftig funktioniert kers
worauf ihr wahrscheinlich alle
ewigkeiten schon gewartet hat the congo
after wars kran crafter was zur hölle
ist dieses wesen an lucas klein gesicht
weg können wir gott würde ich diese
diese augen aber hätte ich mein leben
lang verfolgen übrigens verdichter echt
ganz schön deine haare ich hab ja jetzt
auch schon wieder viel zu lange haare
aber was war das denn bitte lukas
gesicht sieht in meinem gesicht
irgendwie so aus als wäre die
kombination von uns ungefähr fünf- oder
so egal
willst du mit deinen augen sinnvoll hier
drin in der software als klammer ein
kamerateam zoom
jetzt habe ich das auch endlich mal
festgestellt so also wirklich diese
bilder sind göttlich das nimmt glaube
ich aber immer das erste bild von der
google bildersuche und dementsprechend
ist es halt immer das gleiche und bzw
wird nicht mehr so lustig beschreiben
würde bord von crafter wars job hat
bekommt sonst kann auch übel werden
glaube ich oder irgendwas lustige wie
sähe das sich aber nicht auf anhieb
okay das ist ja eigentlich ja wanne und
hier sollte luca irgendwo sein wo
versteckte sich wieder recht manchmal
schwierig suche einfach alle sitzen halt
ab welche alle schlimmstes irgendwie
problem ist der passt das ja auch
farblich an und deshalb wenn es nicht da
ist wo es sein soll ist es so schwer zu
finden
ich finde gerade wirklich nichts also
nee leute muss ich sagen sorry ich finde
sie nicht schreibt man die kommentare
habt ihr lokal irgendwo gefunden
falls ja dann schreibt auch lustig war
jfg wir wissen es ausprobieren
ich hoffe mal dass finis zensieren muss
deshalb wurde fdgb warstory
pkw.de ab hallo leute das wird wie zu
krank jetzt diesen rasern vermuten anti
aging creme irgendwie falsch rum
eingesetzt habe ich gefühlt man okay wir
müssen uns noch was richtig richtig
fettes überlegen für den abschluss
bekommt einen job machen wir nochmal
what ist simon tingel tangel so schreibt
man das hoffentlich richtig
fehlgeschlagen mgs behält darüber ist
die eine gesichtshälfte auf der anderen
seite ist einfach der rest apa red
was grazia grassi
leute dieses wesen
ich bin raus ich war richtig lustig
heute wenn ihr sowas nochmal sehen wollt
öfters anderweitig lass mich wissen
ich fand's auf jeden fall lustig heute
das x zu machen weshalb er macht zwei
videos und bis zum nächsten mal macht es
gut und tschüss